[Music]
i know it wasn't the christmas show that
you expected but that's the beauty of
this place like life it's unpredictable
paul rudd's fifth time hosting saturday
night live looked
a little different yeah it's happening
right now right before our very eyes for
its last show of 2021 snl was forced to
make some drastic last-minute changes a
precaution amid the latest developments
in the coven 19 pandemic leading up to
the show on saturday snl's twitter
account shared this message
quote due to the recent spike in the
omicron variant and out of an abundance
of caution there will be no live
audience for tonight's taping of
saturday night live and the show will
have a limited cast and crew oh this is
your fifth time hosting no no i was just
arrested for the fifth time this week oh
my god you really deserve it thanks
charli xcx was previously slated as a
knight's musical guest but the crash
singer was also forced to cancel her
performances
charlie tweeted she was quote devastated
and heartbroken telling her fans quote i
am currently safe and healthy but of
course very sad without a live audience
and a limited cast snl invited tina fey
and tom hanks to help pick up the slack
and i am not alone isn't that right tina
[Applause]
festive yes i am here and this is not
the smallest audience i have ever
performed for because i have done improv
in a macy's
most of the night was filled with
pre-taped sketches and classic holiday
moments
and before charlie's live appearances
were canceled she was able to knock out
a fun cameo
[Music]
[Music]
plus tina slipped back into one of her
former gigs it really feels like i uh
never left she and michael che performed
a bare bones version of weekend update
telling jokes for their captive yet
limited audience
nasa announced that for the first time
in history a spacecraft has touched the
sun by flying through its upper
atmosphere nasa was finally able to
complete the impossible mission by going
at night
that's smart it's a thinker that's smart
while red's hosting spot might have had
an asterisk the ageless actor was still
honored with the iconic jacket well
there was a whole show planned and i
just can't believe i'm not gonna get my
five-timer jacket or will you
here to bestow this great honor is the
longest tenured cast member mr keenan
thompson congratulations on hosting the
show
four and a half times
wow
oh
gosh look at that it's beautiful look at
this stitching yeah lauren's getting
really good and a fellow club member
even sent his well wishes in a video
oh look it's martin short you're a
member of the five timers club right no
how many times have you hosted it three
huh
[Music]
you